america's crime crisis comes for a
democratic lawmaker front-runner in los
angeles mayor's race and congresswoman
karen bass says thieves broke into her
l.a home over the weekend and stole two
firearms that were quote safely and
securely stored in a brink's lockbox
and only guns were taken from her house
despite cash electronics and other
valuables being visible
bass said she bought the guns years ago
for personal protection and it's no
wonder burglaries are up 15 percent
city-wide this year compared with the
last year and crime has emerged as a
major issue in the mayoral race
bass was even asked about security
earlier this year at a debate watch
congresswoman do you feel safe walking
in i do feel safe i would say a 10. i
feel safe but i do understand that a lot
of people around the city do not feel
safe and i respect that
something doesn't smell quite right
about this story who wants this one i
got i got janine over here greg you both
licking your chopsticks all right go
ahead let me tell you something
she's got two guns that are registered
for which she has no permits okay
only two guns are stolen but they are
quote safely and securely in a brink's
lock box
how did the guy who allegedly is this
hispanic that they were referring to i
mean they didn't tell us how they got a
description since no one was at home
maybe they had one of those ring things
that they have a picture of i don't know
but how does a criminal not take cash
there's no identification number no
fingerprints not take jewelry not take
anything other than a box that you hope
two guns are in you there isn't a glass
cover on a brink's locks box now the one
she has some issues okay as it relates
to the gun she only has it registered
she doesn't have a permit she's had it
for 40 years and never bothered to get a
permit i don't know what's going on but
i'll tell you what all my all my
antennas are up here there's something
totally off no criminal goes in and
doesn't take cash
two unlicensed firearms are missing from
the democrat candidate in la's mayor
race and this morning and they blamed
the hispanic right well they did they
said they have a photograph oh they have
a photo and of course it you know
there's coven covertime so he's got a
mask on
so they don't know
yeah there you have it there you have it
uh and as of this morning um on
america's news room uh only her campaign
had made a comment
and i don't i would i would not want
anyone to violate my home and take my
guns in my lock box it does seem a
little strange i'm not saying it didn't
happen but we need a lot more on this
and rick caruso is the gop
candidate out there
he he would be i think he would be a
really good mayor
and this race is it's going to be very
tough there's so many democrats that
live in los angeles but they are upset
about crime and nationwide people are
upset about crime and i think when the
voting actually happens in november
in the exit polls when you look back and
i think a lot more democrats will lose
than they are thinking right now i think
crime and certainly the border will be
two of the big issues
do you think that they're going to
mysteriously discover these two firearms
in the
campaign office of rick caruso
it's weird maybe maybe the criminal only
takes bitcoin
yeah yeah this story stinks like kill
means gym bag number one
you break into a house you take a safe
and you only steal guns that's a lot of
effort meaning you knew what you were
doing you knew that there was something
that you wanted specifically to get and
that's and that's what happened if only
there were like journalists who would
like care about this kind of story based
purely on its hypocrisy right
journalists really used to like the
hypocrisy story like if it was a pastor
of a church that had an affair with a
church member or maybe a conservative
moralist busted for drugs but here you
got a gun control advocate who loses her
guns the gun control
loses the gun
so when i'm reincarnated i hope i come
back as a democrat because what was i
thinking because like even right now
there's a nevada democrat right who's
accused of murder killed the journalist
imagine that was a republican
he's still getting paid
he's still on the public he's still
gonna he's still getting a paycheck that
is awesome i need that kind of treatment
you remember when harold was saying in
the green room that bass probably shot
two people with the firearms and then
reported them missing
i cannot believe your polygon
[Laughter]
the uh look i i i don't know what to
make of this i think dana had it
probably uh everybody's got an opinion
but dana's position i agree with more
than that
we need to know the facts here uh look
what one of the things i when as i was
reading through all of this uh uh and i
hope you know if we're talking about
ghost guns and demo republican democrats
we'll have their we'll have that whole
feeling about this video hear me out one
sec
we
have a technology
right so those guns may be used and i
hope i hope they're not used by
my only point is the technology if we
have technology to shut down people's
water and heat and air conditioning
these companies do we ought to have the
same kind of technology to make sure no
one can use those guns but for the
person that owns the gun if your guns
are stolen i mean
something good ought to come out of this
i hope all the facts come out of i take
people at the word i imagine the
congresswoman has not done anything here
uh illicit no one is we i don't think
anyone's suggesting that but the story
that i am
i got issues other than the birthday boy
it smells like juicy smolette to me
that wants guns isn't there a whole
point that you can just walk out on the
street and get a gun yeah
you don't need to take it somebody knows
if you took the case you could have
gotten a bigger gun
somebody knew somebody knew that those
guns were there yeah how did they know
that did she take the gun sale did she
talk about the guns did she use those
guns if she did she needed a permit oh
yeah it could have been a handyman they
say it's working around the house to buy
a vegetable than it is yeah that's right
it is
a vegetable
right fresh fruit yeah you were the one
always saying that well i agree with
harold i always trust what the
politicians tell me yeah all right all
right amen hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now